all right so a brand new Scream Six
trailer dropped yesterday and my Lord
Ghost Face hitting up the Big Apple my
dude's gonna be like hey I'm killing me
but yeah there's a lot to unpack so in
this video we're going to be covering
all of the new footage we got new
characters that show up along with why
the heck ghost face is now living in a
New York City studio apartment but with
all of that out of the way a huge thank
you for clicking this I'm your host
Jared the scary movie of The Heavy
spoilers Channel now let's get into
Scream Six
this isn't like any other ghost face
all right so kicking things off Scream 6
changes things up with the surviving
members heading off to college in the
concrete jungle where dreams are made of
however the carpenter sisters PTSD
appears to have followed them right
behind as they are chased into a bodega
by someone wearing a ghost face mask now
this one differs from the later ones in
the trailer this one looks worn a bit
older kind of like how Michael Myers
mask was all like decrepit looking in
the 2018 Halloween rebukal so this one
might be an original mask clearly it
looks like he or she is after the
carpenter sisters as Ghostface gives
this man the business and narrowly
Dodges incoming shotgun fire from the
store clerk instead turning the weapon
back on him and this is such a badass
image of a weathered ghost face just
packing some serious heat there's a
clever disclaimer on the pillar to the
right stating no exchange or refund on
phone cards referencing Ghost Face
always running out of prepaid minutes
asking people what their favorite scary
movies are the two sisters try to sneak
away but some broken glass giz away
their location this could all be a huge
misdirect and just be a robber in a
random mask that they found in like an
alley honestly I think that the police
are probably gonna show up right after
this and smoke this fool we then get a
voiceover from Sam Carpenter talking to
someone I'm assuming it's our new
College roommates or potentially
sorority sisters about her fleeing from
California being Billy loomis's daughter
and also how this evil ghost face
presence has followed her all the way
across the country and how some of them
might be in danger too Sam is holding
the same worn ghost face mask from the
bodega sequence earlier with a bit of
blood on it I still think that that
ghost face is taken out because Sam is
holding the mask with the same navy
jacket that she was wearing in the
bodega so potentially it's the next
morning the police are trying to gather
information from the crime scene it
could be there's a quick sequence
showcasing new and returning characters
first is lyanna liberato as Carly maybe
Sam's roommate we then see Tara standing
with Chad Meeks and if you look on his
sweater you can see black field
University in New York that's the
college they're attending Sam and Mindy
Meeks man that is hard to say standing
with a new character of Allison who I'm
assuming is going to be you know a new
friend or again a roommate they're all
terrified because someone in a ghost
face mask is at their door Mindy tells
Alison to run I'm guessing because she
has no clue who Ghostface is and again
you know is newer to the group so uh
yeah she's screwed my favorite part
though is Kirby Kirby is back baby I
know a lot of people assumed she died in
Scream 4 but there's actually a tease of
her still being alive in Scream five I
think it's like in a list of suggested
YouTube videos that Richie is looking at
but yeah she's back for this one again
it was rumored that she went into law
enforcement after the events of Scream 4
but potentially becoming a detective and
if you look at the guy walking behind
her he's sporting a badge of some sort
so we can assume that they're at a
station and yes she is a detective
interviewing the carpenter sisters after
the bodega attack much like the sisters
it seems like Kirby moved all the way
across the country to get away from the
PTSD of the Ghostface attacks personal
nitpick here but where's the pixie cut
oh my gosh I love that haircut anyway
this might be my favorite part of the
trailer though as we get into
ghostface's new layer first we see
someone had graffitied almost a memorial
to ghost face on the wall the quote of
what's your favorite scary movie is
shown obviously being their iconic
catchphrase starting all the way back in
the original Scream movie this appears
to be an old abandoned theater kinda
reminiscent of the ending of Scream 2 as
the old and new members investigate I'm
curious what actually brought them to
this place or if it's all actually a
trap to get them all in one place and
then close the behind them anyway this
is a whole Treasure Trove of Easter eggs
and references to previous Scream movies
just tucked away whoever this ghost face
is is clearly obsessed with Ghost Face
lore and in the words of Gail a shrine
so if we slow things down the first
police uniform appears to be from
Woodsboro potentially belonging to Haas
or Perkins from Scream 4. the gray shirt
almost cut to shreds is Olivia's from
Scream 4. this mask is ripped directly
from Scream 2 when Sydney is performing
her like interpretive dance in the
theater there's several pieces of stab
memorabilia in the glass cases on the
left and right there's a whole Bevy of
older outfits as you can see Jill
Roberts blue flannel and pants from
Scream 4 Debbie's salt AKA Mrs loomis's
Blazer she wore in screamed too Casey's
boyfriend Steve's varsity football
jacket in the middle they even went as
far as putting the duct tape on the
mannequin's mouth Tatum Ryan Bailey's
shirt and skirt from the first scream
there's Billy's bloodied shirt from the
ending of scream and stews red silk robe
he wore in that film as well
surprisingly if you zoom in and look
closely the old CRT TV that fell on stew
at the end of Scream 1 is also tucked
away by The Robe so like this is a
serious collector like how do you even
get that there's also a flag sporting
the same colors of woods Barrel High I'm
assuming it's their flag the stupid fax
machine from Scream 3 and the star or or
sun stage prop that Derek was hanging
from at the end of Scream 2 tucked away
on the left I probably missed a couple
things so uh let me know in the comments
and also don't forget to stab that like
button and subscribe Button as it helps
us out but now the Holy Grail of the
room are the nine different Ghost Face
outfits on the stage representing the
nine different Ghost Face killers that
there have been to jog your memory
Scream 1 had Billy and Stu Scream 2 had
Mickey and Mrs Loomis Scream 3 had Roman
Scream 4 had Jill and Charlie and lastly
screamed five was Richie and Amber also
it's pretty cool that there's little
name plates at the bottom of each to
show who worn which outfit and if you
zoom into the one in the glass case this
one is the original belonging to Billy
which brings about the theory that I
think Stu is still alive and behind all
of this he's the only OG character that
we've never gotten 100 confirmed or
denied if he's alive or dead so I think
it would be a wild series of events if
we find out that he's been behind the
scenes of this orchestrating it all now
I think that there was a rumor or maybe
it was like an early discarded script
maybe scream three I I can't entirely
remember but it had Stu sort of
mentoring a cult of other ghostfaces
into doing his bidding so with nine
costumes here I could see this sequence
playing out rather than getting the
usual one or two getting a whole Bevy of
them because in that later Subway
sequence it does look like there's you
know more than just one and the main
characters it doesn't look promising for
him sure Matthew Lillard has denied any
sort of involvement but come on Shaggy
say it wasn't you the next sequence is a
bit of an homage to Ghostface calling
their victim first to toy with them that
originated from the first scream Gail's
boyfriend maybe or whoever it is is
snatched by Ghostface in the background
which I absolutely love I love when
slashers do this where they have like
little blurry things happening in the
background but Gail totally seems like
she can handle her own you know you're
like the 10th guy to try this right this
is actually a great self-aware line
because this will be the 10th person to
Don the ghost face mask so great writing
team however much like Dewey and scream
five I don't think Gail is gonna make it
out of this one alive it kind of makes
sense to me to finally hand over the
franchise to an entirely new generation
there's several quick flash moments of
the film it looks like the final
showdown in the same theater where the
ghost face Shrine is and from this shot
of Tara and Sam I'm convinced that there
there's at least a couple ghost faces
because who is she looking at again
fingers crossed for the cult that I
theorized because Chad is seen fighting
one as well and then the Williams police
chief is looking for someone as well
there's several shots of the group
having to scale across an apartment
building to escape Ghostface while he or
she is just about to drop the ladder
very Home Alone of you ghost face and
then a quick look at Tony revolores Gabe
and Samara weaving's Sasha more than
likely they're gonna be like the famed
kill sequence to open the film because
this is the only footage we have of them
but if we do pause on the game shot
there's a poster of vertigo behind him
along with an image of the last podcast
on the left his shirt is also a nod to
the movie Four Flies on gray velvet now
all of these deal with murder cases
crime True Crime fake crime some sort of
crime I Don't Know But True Crime could
potentially be like the running theme of
this one like how funny Would it be that
we find out all that all of these
ghost-faced people are just podcasters
anyway to close the trailer we get our
group of woods Barrel Friends riding the
subway with our first look at another
new group member David played by Josh
segarra now he might look familiar to
you and it's because he played pug in
She-Hulk just a few months ago anyway it
looks like the group is having to escape
Ghostface via the subway on Halloween
night the subway car is filled with
horror slasher and other movie character
references so let's break them all down
for you starting with the guy behind
them dressed as the babadook in the next
shot there's a werewolf mask this is
peach fuzz from the movie creep yes
obscure reference I know along with
Pinhead from the Hellraiser franchise
there's the creep mask from Creep Show
the woman with her back turned is
dressed as Samara weaving's bride
character from the movie ready or not
this is both a nod to her starring in
this movie Scream 6 along with Matt
bettinelli directing both of these films
there's a Jason mask off to the right
that looks similar to the one that he
wears in Friday the 13th Part 8 Jason
Takes Manhattan which seems very fitting
a couple of tethered from Jordan Peel's
us above Jason and then there's a quick
shot of a guy dressed as Freddy Krueger
from Nightmare on Elm Street again a
nice reference to Wes Craven anyway it
looks like the group may be trapped in a
ghost face or several of them get Mindy
potentially some clever editing where
she bites the dust earlier and that's
why she's not pictured with the full
group at the start of this scene but
yeah Scream 6 baby this trailer
surprisingly has me super excited after
being somewhat wishy-washy with Scream
5. but if they bring back stew oh yes
that that kind of like cult angle of
things sounds so interesting to me and
this looks like a more brutal version of
scream than what we got in Scream 5. and
with the line maybe but there's never
been one like me Gail I'm something
different
I have faith they're flipping the script
once again anyway I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the latest Scream 6 trailer
did you catch any other Easter eggs we
missed who's behind the ghost face mask
and are you seeing Scream 6 opening
weekend and I'll let you know we're
currently running a competition giving
away three copies of wakanda Forever on
the 15th of February and all you gotta
do is to get a chance of winning this is
like this video subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below on Scream Six we picked the
comments at random at the end of every
single month and the winners of last
month are on screen right now so if
that's you message us on Twitter at
heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch be sure to check out some
of our other cool videos all the rage is
The Last of Us so check out our episode
one breakdown but with that out of the
way thank you for your constant support
I've been Jared I'll see you in the next
one take care and what's your favorite
scary movie